من الشائع مع اقتراب فصل الشتاء عندما
تصبح الايام ابرد واكثر قتامه الاصابه
بحاله من الكابه الشتويه او ما يعرف
باكتئاب الشتاء لكن يبدو ان هناك ما هو
اخطر وهو الاضطراب العاطفي الموسمي فاا
وفقا لمن تلهف امريكا يعاني نحو 5% من
الاشخاص من الاضطراب الموسمي السنويا وهو
اضطراب ينتج عن انخفاض ساعات الضوء وزياده
ساعه الظلمه وتسبب هذه الحاله انخفاضا في
المساج وانعدام الرغبه في القيام بانشطه
يوميه ويمكن ان تشمل الاعراض نقص الطاقه
صعوبه التركيز مشاكل النوم اضافه للشعور
بالحزن والوهن كذلك التغير في الشهيه
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
انت عايش في مصر
هل تعلم الناس كيف يتعايشون
كثير
لما بتروحي شمال شرق روسيا سيبيريا
الحراره ناقص 50 وناقص 60 بتلاقي بيوت من
الثلج بيجيبوا الثلج
البرد هو شيء تاريخي طبعا والبرد بيلعب
دور كبير بتاسيس الحياه الروسيه حتى
بالوضع العسكري يعني في حروب خاضت الشعب
الروسي عبر التاريخ من الحرب العالميه
الثانيه واحد الهزائم يعني اللي تعرضنا
للجيش الالماني هي كانت بسبب برد موسكو
القارس اللي بيوصل لبعض الاحيان لناقص 40
ناقص 36 طيب
النفسي ونسال الدكتور منور استشاره نفسي
الدكتور اسامه النعيمي دكتور يسعد صباحك
سمعت عبد الجواد منورنا اليوم جاي من مصر
الى دبي 5% من الناس يا دكتور يعانون من
الاكتئاب الموسمي
هل فعلا الفصول تغيرها لها تاثير على
نفسيه
هو عشان تشخص الاكتئاب الموسمي مش مجرد
انخفاض في المزاج لازم ان تظهر كل اعراض
الاكتئاب المعروفه من ضمنها انخفاض المزاج
وانخفاض الفعاليه وزياده الوزن والتراب
انهم كل هذه الاشياء الي ما تتحقق على
موسم المتتاليين مش من اول مره لذلك ينصح
الاشخاص دائما بالعلاج بالضوء لان هو اسلم
انواعه واقل تاثيرا لكن انواع معينه من
الضوء يعني ما يجوز انه يفتحوا الفلورسنت
ويقعدوا تحته لانه كميه الحراره ممكن تؤذي
الجلد وتؤذي القرنيه هم في انواع معينه من
الضوء النشاط المنتظم مهم جدا التزام
بروتين العمل الرياضه والتعرض الى الشمس
همم
دائره اجتماعيه مفتوحه ثم عدم التردد في
طلب المساعده من المختصين نفسهم حتى من
معالجين نفسيين اذا تطور الامر اصبح يؤثر
على وظائف الشخص او تكرر اكثر من مره بعد
اصبح معيق للمصابين ان يقوموا بحياتهم
العاديات
[موسيقى]